miss your hands let me see your hands
let me see your hands drop the knife
drop the knife a California man armed
with a knife is shot by police after
calling 9-1-1 on himself
according to the Los Angeles Police
Department the incident happened on
August 26th officers responded to a call
of a possible assault with a deadly
weapon the 9-1-1 caller was identified
as 53-year-old Angel garrido he told
emergency operators he was going to hurt
somebody hello
so
let me help you
eight
I'll just speak
of what street
North
Northern Street
golden okay uh what happened
right now I'm gonna order somebody
You're Gonna Hurt Somebody
yeah yeah
yes
as the 911 operator tries to get more
information from garito garrido
responded he was armed with multiple
weapons
okay what's your name
okay
I give you the address already do you
have them do you have weapons are you
outside
yes
I have a gun and I have a knife
I'm gonna use it on who okay on yourself
or somebody else
wanna use it okay on yourself or
somebody else
and when I use it
boom okay on who it's gone why what
happened okay
the storm
eight of golden
is that like a apartment or a house
just come is it a house or an apartment
and when they used it
okay okay all right we're gonna go all
right
the dispatcher calmly asked garrido if
he needs to speak with a professional
and garrido says no
you don't want to talk to a professional
figure something out the police
and the police garrido then tells the
operator he was going to hurt whoever
showed up to the location it's an old
and Pierce streets he's almost a gun and
it's going to hurt someone in the room
1847 or the 11 18. identify
right now
it's late it's too late
um
I guess the police going over there so
if you want to talk to us uh you called
to uh get some help right
okay it's too late body cam footage
shows officers rushing to the scene as
they make their way up a narrow Stairway
to the second floor of the building with
guns drawn body camera captures the
officer look around the corner before
signaling that they need backup moving
to the unit coming or not
moments later the officers draw their
guns as they approach the suspect's home
in a second LAPD officer's body cam you
can hear officers again signaling for
more backup before they approach the
suspect
[Music]
a minute later police see the suspect
approached them and if you guys got the
shield
[Music]
garrito can then be seen with a knife in
hand walking toward officers they order
garrido to drop the knife
so
and if you guys have Shield
see
miss your hands let me see your hands
let me see your hands drop the knife
drop the knife according to authorities
the knife was being held with the blade
pointed toward the officers then
officers fire at garrido hitting him and
he tumbles down the stairs in the
aftermath a woman could be heard
screaming as officers try to handcuff
gurito
Garita was taken to a hospital and later
charged with one count of assault with a
deadly weapon on a police officer the
Los Angeles Police Department said in a
statement No officers were injured in
the incident officials say they will
review the incident to make sure the use
of force was within lapd's policies
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Elizabeth Milner